man I got five kids to feed that's
nowhere in this movie it's never said
that's really sad the three titty ladies
in this movie and that was cool but man
Total Recall
so Total Recall is another telling of a
story that's actually a book that has a
different title that I can't think of
right now and in that book there's no
Mars whatsoever so in this movie there
is also no Mars which actually makes it
more accurate to the book than the old
movie with Arnold Schwarzenegger
so when Total Recall Colin Farrell plays
Douglas Quaid he's a guy who's more or
less down on his luck I mean the guy has
a hot-ass wife and a steady job that
being said he's pretty miserable in his
life he's like I know there's something
else out there I want to go to this
recall place and have a mess with my
brain it's always the basis for smart
decisions and after he goes their
hits the fan people like your ass pies
like I'm not a spy he's trying to run
from the government who supposedly
thinks he's a spy then he knows martial
arts but he really shouldn't you don't
know if it's all really you don't know
if it's all in his head because he went
to that recall place he just don't know
problem is if you've seen the old movie
you do know and that was kind of a
bummer for this just really no escaping
that fact if you saw the old movie you
knew you're gonna be like I know all the
twists in this movie I mean this Total
Recall doesn't follow the old movie
verbatim or anything like that it does
have a lot of differences but in terms
of the template that is the plot and any
twists that'll happen in the movie more
or less the same enough to where you
don't feel like you're surprised at all
you're like yeah I've seen this movie
before maybe that's the way it should be
maybe it's not but it does detract from
some enjoyment in this movie I did like
that they had a lot of throwback to the
original Total Recall it made me laugh
there are a few references or a couple
of characters where you're like hey I
know that it makes you feel all cool but
it really shouldn't because every human
being in the theater is also gonna know
what it means
everyone in this movie did their job
really well Colin Farrell kicked ass in
this movie it was good to see him back
in form you know he's been on kind of a
hiatus there were years really like what
happened to that Colin Farrell guy now
he's back he's kicking ass and he did a
good job in Total Recall Kate Beckinsale
plays his wife in the movie as hot as
ever I am waiting for the day where I
see Kate Beckinsale and I'm like oh yeah
finally age caught up to her not today
though and she does a good job in this
movie - she's like the t1000 there was
one scene where she walks on the screen
I was like yeah that's t1000 physically
doesn't look menacing but you know that
thing
kill you Jessica Biel's in this movie
she's the ally that : Farrell has she's
oh hey I know who you are so let's run
from the government together it's what
we need for a movie so they do with us
we have a movie she was good to but I
didn't feel like she stood out she's the
character where I'm like they could have
cast one of a few people as her Jessica
Biel could have been traded out but I'm
glad she wasn't because hey she's hot
too two hot chicks one action movie does
life get any better where's the popcorn
yeah I enjoy the little things in life
that's one of the little things I enjoy
Bryan Cranston's in this movie it's just
funny because Bryan Cranston has been in
so many movies this year he's the guy
who has a steady paycheck on Breaking
Bad and then he just plays little parts
in a bunch of but the dude always
kills it he's a great actor and if we
can live in a world where Bryan Cranston
is literally in everything I would elect
that's the way we should live Bryan
Cranston in everything God already puts
a smile on my face this movie does have
its own direction it takes in the sense
that there's no Mars so you know that's
going to be that thing that Colin
Farrell has to deal with that's bigger
than the situation you think that made
sense right no well that's what it is
situations compound on themselves they
reveal a bigger situation he has to deal
with that in this movie it is not Mars
it's something else entirely and I
actually did enjoy and the action scenes
were really cool too the lot of
shootouts a lot of scenes where Colin
Farrell's running on rooftops and the
camera follows him into a window that he
crashes through things like that that
really look cool and stylish and almost
like uncharted 3 a bit of uncharted 3 a
lot of shaky-cam know there was that
sometimes it makes me dizzy us watching
the movie going and can you stop that
blue so in the end this movie's really
cool really enjoyable has a really cool
yet familiar premise the actors are good
in it the characters are great in it if
you've seen the old one you're going to
enjoy this movie a bit less because you
know ultimately everywhere the plots
going to go and in that there's no real
surprises in this movie free it's a bit
of a bummer but it's still enjoyable to
watch I will say Total Recall is a good
time no alcohol required this movie
would not hold a candle if this was May
June or July but it's August now this is
a good movie for August it's not gonna
win any awards but it's gonna entertain
you all right so Total Recall what do
you prefer the old one or the new one
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you